everybody loves a good comeback story
and I hope that this is the return of
Jack Ma so he built Alibaba became one
of the most successful entrepreneurs on
the planet and then he criticized the
Chinese government in 2020 and then he
disappeared and now he's back and he's
running a farming tech company and
listen jack is not perfect I don't know
him personally but I loved his wisdom I
loved his humor I loved his stories and
I respect the business that he built and
I'm glad that he's back and I hope that
he can do something special in the
farming sector everybody loves a good
comeback story so hopefully this is his
and you've been beaten down or you took
a big loss let's cheer for your comeback
story too believe